mgtow is men going their own way so
what does that mean so so you can go
yeah
so mgtow is let's say there's a spectrum
right okay and in the middle is like the
balanced perspective you want to be the
most balanced possible far left is like
male feminist the guy at the rally with
the [ __ ] hat on
[Laughter]
do you honestly believe i'm like no
because this is my thing like they
people believe that i'm this like the
guy with the [ __ ] hat
when all i say i'm like just don't why
you have to be a dick about it like a
lot of this feels like
i'm the victim being a man is so hard
women
they just
are i have to be like dude just shut the
[ __ ] up
don't be a dick to women
just be the best version of yourself
don't be a dick to anyone
that's it and like it's not it i feel
like a lot of the red pill is also like
yeah it's like very pessimistic like
yeah and so it's like real i'm dude i'm
just being a realist but everything is
pessimism there's no light i love that
because going back to that to me
it goes i asked i asked robert greeno
the 48 laws of power ask them a question
i said i said from all your research
from all your understanding from all
things that you've done do you believe
most human beings
have good intentions and occasionally do
bad things or do most human beings have
bad intentions and occasionally do good
things
robert greene told me
he believes most human beings have good
intentions and occasionally do bad
things what do you believe
i agree with that i think that most
people have good intentions and they'll
occasionally do some bad things and
obviously there's some a few bad apples
and i think there was a stat that
um 95 of the this was a former cia fbi
operative he came into valuetainment he
said well you know 95 of the world
does do good things wants to do good
things but then the five percent but if
you take five percent of eight billion
people 100 and that's you know quick
math a couple hundred million it's like
yeah that's why you got so many [ __ ]
crazy people out there and i mean i
totally agree with that i think most
people do good things and just arrive
good intentions occasionally do bad
things but then those good intentions
are subjective right because i think
take the example with putin right now he
thinks he's doing a good thing yeah the
entire world is like dude he can [ __ ]
invade a country but he's like i gotta
do it for russia yeah you disagree with
robert greene i agree with him okay and
so i asked him is this true for men and
is this true for women he said yes
so it goes back to that framework what
do you believe the other person's
intentions are
so one of my biggest criticisms of the
red pill movement
happened because most people don't know
this about the podcast is that i try to
be as balanced as possible
i try to get far right and far left i
want to i want i want um roland martin i
want umar johnson i also want candace
owens you know i i want everybody i want
to learn from everybody of course and so
i got some guys who people consider like
the opposite of bread pill i interviewed
them what is that that's blue pill what
does that mean yeah they would they
would consider these guys blue pill men
i don't consider them that but the
internet would consider them that so
what's blue so basically the concept of
blue pill is going back to the matrix is
like you're oblivious to the truth and
you're living in a lie so you're so like
basically just want to feel secure you
don't want to have bad things happen you
you don't want the harshness of the real
world
so like basically a person who would
quote unquote be blue pills a person
who's naive to the realities of life
they think you know
women are these perfect angels and if
you just love them just enough every
woman will love you equally right it's
not it either yeah yeah it's
neither right
so i'm gonna explain to you the
criticism because i i hope that i'll
answer your question so i went on tour
with three of the biggest dating coaches
in the world and i was a camera guy
i went on tour with three of the biggest
data coaches in the world it was um
derrick jackson the guy red pill guys
hate
um they really hate this guy my mentor
stefan labosia is a beast and a guy who
another guy they don't really like name
ace metaphor i want to talk with these
three guys
and on this tour
we there it was 95 women
and we would go to these venues
thousands of women
atlanta miami new york man it's fun
but
and i sat and i was a camera guy and
they at the end of each show they would
do a q a
and they would do this q a and it will
get these women to talk about their
issues and ask the guys questions
and during this time is when i learned
the most about women because i was
actually meeting not online not reading
a book not watching a bunch of guys
bringing girls that they've chosen and
curated i just met thousands of
different women and got to hear them all
talk and i would hear them talk about
things about men
and you would hear these generalizations
all men cheat men are liars why do men
do this why do and you would hear them
complain
and then you'll see a woman who's
respectfully like 350 pounds and was
like we're all the good guys that all i
find is guys want sex with me the men
are not serious it's like well maybe you
got in your best shape and you got
physically fit you could change your
outcomes radical accountability radical
accountability so i would i would
talk about radical so i would see i
would see all these things and i would
be like this is crazy like
they they first they would over
generalize
then they would not take accountability
so
move forward fast forward to now i'm in
the men's space
and literally the same things i heard
from the women i hear from the guys
radical generalizations of women usually
like david said from a pessimistic
worldview because the truth is
pessimistic yeah the truth is that most
women are actually good people with good
attention do bad things the truth is
most women are selfish hypergamous
people out to get you to take half your
money to take custody of your kids from
you
that's these messages that being
communicated and then there's a lack of
accountability well the average women
don't want average men
these girls don't want us there's not
accountability where yo do you know if
you put in the work for the next five
years to become your best version of
yourself you would no longer be average
you if you held three years if you put
in three years of work you would no
longer be average so that that whole
sentence wouldn't apply to you i would
see both these things and i would see
how bitter and hurt the women were
because if because the reason you're so
emotional is because you were bitter and
you were hurt by a god that's what
caused generalizations you these women
were hurt by men they become bitter they
then they generalize
and then i saw the guys the same thing
guys would call me
guys would call me in
and i will see a lot of these guys are
hurt when your girlfriend cheated on you
how do you feel you're hurt when your
wife divorced you took your money how do
you feel you're hurt when your baby mama
took away custody of your children
you're paying child support how do you
feel you're hurt when a girl of your
dreams told you that you're ugly loser
i'll never be with you how do you feel
you're hurt the guys are hurt and i
called it for what it was and they're
acting emotional not logical is that
basically what you're saying i'm not
saying that
yes but my main point was that they got
offended when i said they were hurt yeah
when you are hurt yeah and they they
take it like it's a sign of weakness as
a man to be hurt i've been hurt you've
been hurt we've all been hurt nothing
wrong with a man being hurt i'm just
calling it for what it is
and so to me like i said the the problem
with all these things is at the end of
the day my goal is that if any man is
listening to this message
if they take anything from what we
communicated
if you simply view the opposite gender
as the villain and you the victim you
will never win exactly you will never
win you will not it's just impossible
because it's because think about it
imagine there's a woman who views men as
the villain and she's a victim what a
man of character what a man of integrity
would a man of sensibility want to view
for no she would be too negative he
won't want to stay over for long so the
same thing is true as a man and also if
you are a man
instead of simply being bitter if you
want to be better put in the work to
become the best version of yourself
physically emotionally spiritually
financially if you commit to that for
three years of your life
see what happens to your outcomes
compound interest
literally
[Music]
you